I do however have a recommendation for
you it's been a while we've been so busy
on the show that I've not been able to
do recommendations but I have one today
I've been reading just as much just not
doing recommendations I just finished up
the third edition of Nobel Prize winner
Robert Schiller's book irrational
exuberance this book was initially
published in March of the year 2000 and
it and now is in its third edition and I
am so conflicted about the book because
the but not about the quality of the
book but about how I should deal with
what the book says because Robert
Shiller is making very very clear that
he sees major bubbles right now in the
stock market and in the housing market
major major bubbles now as you may know
my philosophy of investing is don't try
to time the market do not try to time
the market if you have some kind of
philosophy or program that you're on of
regularly contributing to an investment
account to a retirement account whatever
don't try to figure out oh now is a
better time to buy right now isn't so
good so I'll wait three months and then
then buy three times as much into my
mutual funds over the long term you're
better off not timing the market and
just dollar-cost averaging in however
Robert Shiller makes a very good case
that right now the market the stock
market which Donald Trump is taking
great pleasure in reminding us about how
well it's doing is drastically
overvalued and that is a reason not to
continue buying up stock so I don't know
what the answer is and I posted to my
Instagram account that I was reading the
book maybe about a week ago and someone
said you know David these books are
interesting but if you take them
literally you would not make the wisest
financial decisions in the sense that if
you read Robert Schiller's irrational
exuberance and then decide well I've got
to get out of stocks you could
accumulate taxes on short-term gains
there could be all sorts of other
implications and if you're in it for the
long haul
it might not end up making that much of
a difference to get out now and try to
rebuy at a lower rate so anyway a lot of
interesting stuff in the book it also
destroys efficient market theory
efficient market theory is the idea that
at all times stock prices
and you could apply this to housing
prices as well they always reflect all
relevant information now that can't
possibly be true because if at all times
stock prices reflect all relevant
information they would reflect the fact
that there is money to be made on
particular stocks and thus there would
no longer be money to be made on those
particular stocks so you know me I have
a background in in sort of rational
actor economics neoclassical economics
but I think it's basically bogus and
understanding how the real world works
and I think that behavioral economics
and and market psychology tell us a lot
more about how markets actually work and
this book also builds on that idea so I
couldn't recommend it more highly
irrational exuberance by Nobel Prize
winner Robert Shiller you can use the
link in the video description on YouTube
to use to buy the book and send us a
little kick back and you can also go to
david pakman.com slash recommendations
and anything you buy there will send us
a kickback if you buy it through amazon
it's the Friday show let's take a break
glad you're with us today